schwarze löcher bringen den tod wenn ein
stern in die nähe eines schwarzen lochs
gerät wird er auseinander gerissen doch
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam ein lang
gehütetes geheimnis der schwarzen löcher
gelüftet sie können unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen auch sterne zum leben
erwecken
ziemlich verrückt wenn man weiß wie
schwarze löcher eigentlich alles
aufsaugen und schon bald werden wir
wahrscheinlich so etwas auch beobachten
können rott jetzt mal klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen vorab noch
eine kleine bitte wir wollen kriegst du
im jahr werbefrei machen bei einem video
pro monat haben wir und ihr es schon
geschafft helft mit und werdet mitglied
hier unter dem video
draufklicken und uns mit einem kleinen
betrag unterstützen immer wenn genug
zusammenkommen schalten wir vor einem
monatlichen video mehr die werbung ab
sind also jetzt schon zwölf videos pro
jahr zusammen gekommen und jetzt geht es
endlich los
sie sind gleichzeitig die größten und
die kleinsten objekte im weltall ihr
zentrum also das gestirn ist vermutlich
unendlichkeit und der ereignishorizont
also die grenze nach deren überschreiten
es weder für materie noch für licht eine
wiederkehr gibt die ist unfasslich
riesig das größte was es im weltall gibt
er vor kurzem hat ein amerikanisches
astronomenteam ein äußerst schwieriges
loch entdeckt seit mehr als elf jahren
frist ist die überreste eines sterns
denen es einmal zerrissen hat das ganze
passiert in der galaxie ngc 5813 im
sternbild der jungfrau der appetit von
schwarzen löchern kann gigantisch sein
ihr größtes talent materie aufsaugen
wenn es keine materie rund um ihr
schwerefeld mehr gibt warten sie
geduldig ab wie sie wieder zuschlagen
können und materie verschlingen danach
stoßen sie einen strahl an partikeln aus
dazu juli komme ford von der university
of colorado boulder die das ganze mit
menschlichem verhalten assoziiert
schwarze löcher sind ganz schön stressig
aber sie haben keine sehr guten
tischmanieren
doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus
den usa anhand eines modells
herausgefunden dass schwarze löcher auch
anders können der sie sind wohl auch in
der lage neue sterne entstehen zu lassen
wo dafür müssen einige voraussetzungen
gegeben seien bei dem stern muss es sich
um einen
dessen zwerg handeln also eher ein
kleiner stern der sich im letzten
stadium seines lebens befindet das
schwarze loch selbst muss mittel schwer
sein denn sonst würde es den weißen
zwerg entweder komplett ignorieren oder
aber komplett verschlingen
nach angaben des forschungsteams läuft
das ganze dann so ab kommt der weiße
zwerg in die nähe des schwarzen loches
verdichtet er sich gleichzeitig und
dehnt sich aus dieser prozess wird in
der fachsprache auch als teile des
hradschin event bezeichnet da sich der
stern wie gesagt im endstadium befindet
ist die kernfusion in ihm bereits zum
stillstand gekommen also erleuchtet gar
nicht mehr so hell oder ist quasi gar
kein stern mehr
doch durch das zusammenziehen was durch
die kräfte des schwarzen loches
ausgelöst wird kann die kernfusion noch
einmal aktiviert werden zwar nur für
eine kurze zeit aber immerhin ein
absolut spektakuläres ereignis das alles
konnte bisher nur in modellen beobachtet
werden und das aus einem kuriosen grund
forschungsteams konnten in unserem
universum nämlich bisher kein einziges
schwarzes loch mit mittlerer größe
aufspüren
stattdessen wurden immer nur entweder
schwarze löcher mit einer masse von etwa
100 tonnen oder aber mit mehr als
100.000 tonnen aufgespürt doch
theoretisch gesehen spricht spricht
eigentlich nichts dagegen dass es auch
exemplare gibt die in der mitte liegen
also eine masse von etwa 1000 bis 100000
tonnen aufweisen möglicherweise könnten
genau diese langersehnten schwarzen
löcher durch das phänomen des teil des
hradschin events aufgespürt werden was
ein enormer fortschritt wäre so das
forschungsteam in der pressemitteilung
das problem derzeit gibt es noch keine
instrumente die die bei diesem ereignis
entstehen in gravitationswellen messen
können
doch genau diese würden uns endlich auf
die spur der mittelschweren schwarzen
löcher führen aber da sind wir ja mit
der entwicklung relativ weit schon nach
dem in nagoya hier auf der erde zum
ersten mal gravitationswellen gefunden
wurden soll 2034 der europäische
gravitationswellen direktor ins all
geschickt werden statt ein paar
kilometern größe wird dieses system aus
drei satelliten die mehrere millionen
millionen kilometer voneinander entfernt
sind bestehen
wow damit wird es auch mehrere
hunderttausend mal empfindlicher als
lego sein und solche entdeckung werden
dann endlich möglich ja hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken existieren
wir in einem schwarzen loch ja und wenn
ja kein video mehr zu diesem und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann folgt mir auch nur da bekommt ihr
von mir vor allen anderen
das neueste video ganz unabhängig von
der abo box hier auf youtube die ja bei
dem ein oder andere nicht so ganz wird
perfekt funktioniert ja und dafür da
drauf klicken und gerne auch ein abo da
lassen und natürlich nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen bis dahin bleibt dran